alors il est accusé d'agression sexuelle
les faits remontent au 4 octobre 2013
une jeune journaliste qui a aujourd'hui
33 ans et qui avait 25 ans au moment des
faits a déposé plainte au commissariat
du 16ème à paris voilà pour pour dire ce
qui s'était passé pour elle à l'époque
alors donc les faits remontent à 2013
donc la plaignante journaliste de la
chaîne était invité par le patron d'un
grand patron de la chaîne à un concours
de péter ça en corse l'open de calvi
donc jean jacques bourdin est également
invitée alors c'était plus que ça ce que
c'était vraiment l' invité vip c'était
lui qui devait voilà
c'est lui qui devait qui devait voilà
permettre à l'événement d' avoir des
retentissements dans toute la presse de
l'époque donc c'était vraiment l' invité
vip c'était la figure du concours de
pétanque de l'open de calvi à ce moment
là alors la plaignante donc sur le
devant d'un talent inné une présence qui
aurait freiné la journaliste qui
déclinerait l'action extrêmement tendues
avec lui déjà avancé alors en fait elle
a travaillé avec lui quelques années
auparavant et ça a été très compliqué
alors se sont pas pour des faits
d'agression sexuelle mais visiblement il
était en conflit et du cou à cette
époque quand elle travaillait dans son
émission de radio elle a été écartée des
équipes parce qu'elle ne s'entendait pas
du tout avec lui donc en fait comme ce
qui s'est passé c'est que lorsque elle a
travaillé ensuite pour bfm et le patron
de la chaîne de l'époque lui a proposé
d'aller donc avec avec toutes les
équipes à ce fameux concours de pétanque
et là dessus elle apprend que
effectivement jean jacques bourdin va
être l'invité vip donc elle est
extrêmement réticente parce que
justement elle ne s'entendait pas avec
lui et elle décide quand même d'y aller
mais elle met une condition et demande à
ce que son frère l'accompagnent d'accord
voilà donc donc qu'ils arrivent de il
arrive à calvi il s'installe dans un
superbe hôtel cinq étoiles où se
trouvent également jean jacques bourdin
et le lendemain matin elle décide à 6
heures du matin d'aller
dans la piscine et selon ses dires et
selon le dépôt de plainte jean jacques
bourdin alors et l'aurait retrouvée dans
la piscine milliards hasard en fait il y
aussi les italiens et décide d'aller
dans la piscine à 6 heures du matin
auquel elle y était et à 6 heures du
matin il serait venu la rejoindre dans
cette piscine et puis ça aurait commencé
par des questions très gênante situation
vraiment bizarre et puis très vite bah
ça dégénère et là jean jacques bourdin
lui aurait sauté dessus alors qu'elle
était dans la piscine est elle n'avait
pas alors il aurait tenté un
rapprochement ils l'auraient ils
auraient ils ont essayé ils devraient
essayer de l'embrasser voilà elle est là
papier c'est ce qu'elle décrit dans son
dépôt de plainte est la papier elle se
débat et finalement elle réussit à
sortir de cette piscine est selon ce
qu'elle a raconté aux enquêteurs jaj
jean jacques bourdin lui aurait crié au
moment où elle sortait de cette piscine
de toute façon moi je tiens toujours ce
que je veux d'accord alors ensuite c'est
donc c'est cette phrase inquiets qui est
maman retenu au wifi il reconnaît avoir
pris un bain dans la piscine avec cette
personne mais évidemment ni dément toute
tentative d'agression sexuelle alors la
jeune femme qui a quitté la chaîne
depuis aurait reçu plusieurs mails de
sms insiste on sait ce qu'elle dit de la
part de jean jacques bourdin et à la run
aux enquêteurs un seul message dans
lequel il est écrit tu me tendent tous
les matins trois petits points j'aime
ton regard voilà c'est ça c'est
exactement ça c'est là elle a transmis
donc donc ce ce cet email pour prouver
certainement sa bonne foi
l or n'a pas transmis d'autres donc pour
l'instant on attend de voir jean jacques
bourdin n'a pas encore été entendu par
les enquêteurs donc la sphère est en
cours alors deuxième question sans citer
son nom l'indiqué la victime présumée
c'est une journaliste septième
journaliste passionné journaliste de bfm
de bfm qui a fait également deux de la
radio sur sur rmc café de l'antenne
selon le parisien cette journaliste
passé souvent juste avant lui à
l'antenne été amenés à travailler avec
lui à de nombreuses reprises la tension
était à son comble entre les deux
journalistes tous la volonté de la jeune
femme de ne plus travailler avec lui
c'est ça donc c'est voilà donc
voilà le travail toujours là dans
l'audiovisuel toujours se sent
aujourd'hui elle estime que voilà elle a
33 ans allait elle est dans une dans une
vie de famille posé et elle a décidé
c'est pour ça avec tout ce qui se passe
les mouvements me to hell a décidé
qu'aujourd'hui elle devait elle devait
parler